With more than 1,000 patents to his name,...
...Thomas Edison is one of the most celebrated inventors in history.
But does he really deserve credit for his most famous invention, the light bulb?
The real story is more complicated than you might imagine.
Almost 40 years before Edison was granted a patent for an electric lamp in 1880,...
...an Englishman named Frederick de Moleyns...
...claimed the first patent for a filament-based incandescent lamp.
In de Moleyns's patented design, an electric current heated powdered charcoal...
...between two platinum wires in an evacuated glass tube.
Unfortunately, such early light bulbs weren't commercially viable.
The platinum filaments were too expensive and burned out too quickly.
De Moleyns was just one of the inventors working on lighting up the world.
Another Englishman named Joseph Swan actually demonstrated a working lamp...
...with a carbon filament in early 1879,...
...nearly a year before Edison's version debut.
But despite Swan's successes, his bulbs were not useful for consumers either...
...as they still burned out too quickly to be an affordable solution.
Finally, in October 1879, Edison had a breakthrough...
...when he realized that a very thin carbon filament with high electrical resistance...
...was needed to make a light bulb practical.
After testing as many as 6,000 different materials,...
...he settled on carbonized bamboo to make his filaments.
And by early 1880, Edison's bulbs could last some 600 hours.
In fact, the bulb he created is very similar to the light bulbs we use today.